charting right now on
the down the seat belt signs
off the seat belt signs off it's not a
disturbance once you once you it's right
here babe have a seat I am I'm have a
seat okay so watch me bless him so I
used to sing on planes long time ago I
just found
out you're instigating you're
instigating
ooh ooh I'm going say this ooh it ain't
cuz you use chch
language watch me bless them it's not
because you use your church language
that you're not being
Blasphemous okay what's up with you at
the bars I'm just saying God D I just
say and another one because you use
Church language that a Blas for real
some people love to be like very
religious words while they shading you
like they're doing like a benediction
kind of thing but it's actually just
straight up shade from the devil I don't
like that she said watch me bless him
bless what calm down okay girl calm down
Jesus did you're already a whole last
instigator with the camera out all right
and you trying to yeah no I'm I'm
backing up I'm up for two gramys my very
first time you
guys my name is Bobby
storm and I'm for two Grammys I sing for
the Lord and my song is out on all
platforms it's called we can't forget
them Michael McDonald cleared it Warren
G is on the original record as well it's
with
only what is happening right
now
you realize can you explain to me what
the is going on bro the plan's
trying to take
off and she's trying to sing for the L I
don't know what but she's just having
this speech it's just not the time
though did you research this lady I did
not research I I know her name is Bobby
storman and she's popular Bobby Bobby
what Bobby storm I want to share this
with you guys I wanted to do it when I
first got on the plane but I was like
you know I haven't done this in a while
I've gotten to the next status so are
you able to be quiet
[Applause]
that old man is softspoken but you could
hear the uh the the I'm tired the
S I got a real job I ain't
here to hear you talking about your
accomplishments and to be fair to him
nobody else cares either they have to if
this is the end and people are getting
off the plane people just want to go
home they want to do their nobody
asked to be halted by people waiting to
go off the plane
yeah I thought it was takeoff it's
actually The Landing not to D
plane but they're enjoying it so while
we're sitting here could I please I'm
not enjoying it so I'm asking you can
you be
quiet that's a yes or no answer please
am I going to go to jail if I don't can
you please answer my question are
you I don't know what is up with people
wanting to miss with flight attendant I
do not
know what is up with you and that like
what the possible ramification of
pissing off a flight attendant and what
they can do and the way he's talking he
looks like he's an in charge he's the in
charge he's the Top Flight on every
flight there's an inch look at his
outfit he's 100% he's the in charge okay
the person why you trying to piss why
did you choose him today but look at
where the video started the video
started with her standing up in the
middle of the aisle then he told her to
sit down that means she was trying to do
her speech standing up he's like yo get
to your seat and they having a back and
forth she gets to her seat she gets
louder talking to people
so she being a Str let's keep watching
am I going to go to jail if I don't can
you please answer my question are you
willing and able to be quiet right now
I'm doing what the Lord is telling me to
do I'm asking you a
question don't don't don't say the
Lord's name when you just talking about
your own ego no you know some people
talk about feelings they get they be
like well the Lord Propel no boo boo no
that's your own inner demons that's your
need for attention that's your need to
be disruptive did the Lord tell you to
make this man's job job harder for no
reason is that what the Lord told you
right do you have some Divine ability to
Guess that some people love evoking God
when it comes to their own Shenanigans
be it evil disruptiveness anything else
imagine every time a YouTube frankster
did some he said the Lord
propelled me to do this work stop don't
bring Jesus into your mess too many
people want to bring up everyone else
into their mess oh well I as a black no
as
you as
you that's it
that's one thing I don't like you know
what you should have said yo get
the off my plane she like well the
lord well the Lord propels me to tell
you to get off all this
plane I'm asking you a question yes or
no I'm your flight leader I need you to
follow my instruction my instruction for
you to answer my question are you able
to be quiet what do you guys
think I'm asking you ma'am I'm asking
you guys what do you guys think okay if
you're not able to be to follow my
instruction you will not be taking this
flight a okay are you able to be quiet
that's the case then that's fine if you
were the person in charge of it all I'm
your flight leader yes if you the person
in charge of it all then that's fine all
right thank
you so I'll sing it on alone for y'all
in the back if that's okay all right so
the song is called we can't forget them
all right and you can download
it I don't know the the issue no one
else has ever had an issue but it's
father thank you
[Music]
PR do without I'll be out
of
iine got
learn
[Music]
for so just so you know if you're on
this flight you have been thank you so
much you got to clap on the low I know
thank you so much so look up Maverick
City Maverick city has an album out
right now they are a contemporary gospel
group and I have been blessed to be a
part of that album that's called we
can't forget them yep we can't forget
them and it's available everywhere it's
on the Billboards so you know people
like that you know they Spirits a little
they can't accept it but I'm here to
spread what God needs me to spread I'm
here to spread that because that's
what's gotten me where I am I quit my
job in October of last year and I just
went out by faith and now here I am so
remember this face and Chase the storm
all right y'all B obbi storm like the
weather thank you guys for sure thank
you guys and Bobby you're a what now a
two-time gramy now yes just as of today
two time Grammy nominated with hey you
guys it's rest day for me so the hair is
looking a little crazy but I wanted to
follow up with you guys on Delta um they
did reach out to me so whoever
called um I I I can't say thank you cuz
I don't want this man to be
reprimanded um where he loses his job I
simply want us to keep in mind how to
treat each other
and um there was no rules being broken
um and it was just me spreading my joy
with people after they gave me the go to
do so so I just hope that if he watches
this he's able to learn a valuable
lesson on how to treat other people but
I just want to say you guys can stop
reaching out to Delta they have
apologized and they are fans of Maverick
City I'm going to give you all my
general thoughts you can of reecho some
of the stuff you said before
listen it isn't God it's just your
pride that's all I'm going to say man
don't don't mention none of this stuff
about Jesus don't mention other stuff
about listen whether it's things you
should be doing or things you shouldn't
be doing people love to evoke God to
remove their own agency in a lot of
situations or their own
responsibility you don't want to admit
your pride so you just use God as a
shield right oh get a prenup no I'll let
God handle it okay well get life
insurance no I'll let God handle it get
insurance for your car no I'll let God
handle it it's like people just use that
to sometimes abdicate their own
responsibilities and
situations I don't I don't rock with it
okay I'm not somebody who plays with God
lightly I don't think that cool and
when I see religious people using that
to just Advocate as one of the many
reasons why organized relationship
religion sometimes look goofy to me
because of that I just hate it I
hate it God created you gave your brain
the ability to think to use your own
stuff don't be calling them on every
little frivolous thing that you got
going on your life every time you want
to get a bit of attention and you up on
Instagram and you posting a thirst trap
that's not God propelling you to do that
that's your own ego all this
talk about like oh the reason why I
wanted to sing before the plane takes
off and not when it uh when it lands is
because God needs to tell me when to do
it no it's because you just want
attention and you know everyone's
standing
up so they can't see you you want to do
it before because then everyone's
sitting down like you see that's what
you said you just don't want to admit
it's a pride thing I that's why I don't
like so that's my main thing as far as
her being difficult and making five P
jobs bad Hey listen it's just the
audacity for me go
ahead huh oh mental health no cuz you
can't talk to these people you can't
talk logic with the people like that
everything they going to say is God God
God God God no you you cannot take
accountability for your thing and what
you're saying you cannot talking with
this with people like that is
impossible you cannot it's not based on
logic it's based on whatever they take
it their interpretation of what God is
and given them and in their head they're
the hero of their story so they're right
and they're anointing by God so God
wants them to do right even if they do
wrong it's because God wanted it to be
and when and when it was God's plan and
when it's not it's a lesson so you can
never really do wrong you can never be
like I'm sorry it's either God's plan or
my lesson I don't I never lose it's
lessons you cannot talk to the people
Dash that thing away man I'm not staying
near that I'm not going oh that's
because it's God's work because you're
evil yeah I'm evil I don't give a
all right you can't talk to the people
and you cannot have sense of that and
it's very very frustrating and
the amount of energy you have to do to
deal with people like that
hypothetically what if the flight
attendant was like well God's propelling
me to tell you to shut the up so
what happens there like which one is
actually invoking God the G that can the
person that can sing
better but God is telling me you're
wrong no that's not that's not God
that's the devil this gu as God I'm
telling you man I've been I think the
devil's doing that's making you want to
sing that's the problem you think I know
cuz God tells me man it's not God that
tells you you have doubt if you think
it's because you have doubt and that's
the devil I've I've I've been in that
church thing all my life my guy hey you
should never put a Charizard versus a
squirtle okay you are a Charizard in
this domain my guy it's is but you but
you see how you talk about it's the same
thing but on the difference is whenever
you talk about nerd like Pokemon
when you talk about nerd like
Pokemon it makes sense because there's
still a hierarchy in there in this thing
everybody thinks that they anointing and
there's no talking to them they're we
you I've dealt with that my whole
life it's God you trying to bring you
trying to BR I'm coming back so this is
like every anime protagonist I'm going
to go through my training Arc and then
I'm going to come back and hit you with
the craziest logic yo don't mess with me
bro this dude hit Hey listen God I know
you got I was like oh but that's
what it is you hit me with the good
argument yeah yeah cuz you think yeah
don't think I don't think you have to
imagine two people arguing saying
they're boting it's impossible God is
speaking to them there's no way you can
fight middle ground and you see that in
church cuz like how can I how can I tell
you to doubt your own faith BR you you
see that in church and it's great when
she hit a fan like that that is a
wonderful thing this girl being
difficult for no reason and I'm going
say this again I hate
flying do you hate flying I can bring
this s back 100 I hate flying Li
I hate waiting at the airport I hate
dealing with TSA I hate being ass stupid
where you going here what's the address
who knows the add to the hotel or saying
get who you going to meet a girl why cuz
we how been why do
you want to know why do you need to know
this information now I'm just like is
this I've seen you on planes and you you
you're pretty you're more giddy than me
you love flying that's the that's the
most don't troll me don't troll me no
I'm not trolling you that's the most
time I've seen you fly is when we take
flights and then you're having fun with
everybody and despite the fact no
that's not true yes it is that's cuz it
was early morning and I had some
energies not because we were flying on
the plane we didn't even talk CU we
we're not sitting on the we were not
even sitting together like what are you
talking about we're not talking you were
sitting over there I was sitting over
here you no no no the whole you talking
about the whole process the CSA and this
and that through that whole process you
were Mr yappity yap yap yap happy what
was the length of the flight I don't
remember two
hours that's a bus ride who cares
okay that's why you was happy there's a
difference between a plane ride of 6
hours and a bus ride cuz God told me
that you
like no you don't like flying and I know
I fly I I'm not even going to Asia cuz
it's 30 hours I'm trolling oh you come
to Japan I'm never going once I look at
the flight L I'm like I'm not going
would you go let's say like to Europe
and then after that do another thing to
there and I can't leave my place for
more than two weeks after two weeks I
want to I want to go home absolutely I'm
mad at you yeah I know yeah yeah so it's
just not worth it so I'm just like I'm
just not flying to a lot of places too
far I don't like flying I just hate
every aspect of like waiting at airport
sitting around doing nothing eating
food then going through the
bathrooms going on the planes oh my God
I I hate it I hate it anyways doesn't
matter I hate flying that's what I was
trying to say and then you got dumb
asses like this come on talk about God
Propel me listen I don't know if this is
a devil propelling
me Shut the up making this video
worse right now I got no time what are
you talking about hey a little song can
make the flight better yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and you're
assuming and you're assuming you're
assuming the person singing is going to
be
good yeah yeah one of that time you them
Ice JJ Fish
God that told me to was the song
I
just like that I don't know is the
fight fun now go ahead Ice JJ tell
me sing it
I
just with the with the teeth with the
teeth like fingers hey hey hey straight
out of
alien okay yeah I
just now y'all got this cuz God God told
her cuz God told them no I don't want to
hear no Mormons on no flights I don't
want to hear none of these people no one
doing no gospel speeches I don't want to
hear any speech I don't want to hear Pro
Palestine
when we land talk your you don't
want to hear no I don't want to hear
nothing what the what the was
that yo watch the
pain I don't know what that was I don't
know what that was that was crazy I
don't know what that was that was crazy
that gave me like making me anxious
right
now gave me gooseb you know
what y we to end this video do
yeah you don't want to hear that do the
Trump
sound that's not how the sound goes you
know the one the bad trumpet
noise
[Music]
I don't know why this guy sound effects
always kill me anyway I'm going to stop
I'm getting gooseb let's know what you
guys you have don't you have messages
for them like like links and like
that that they like we have links and
merch we have a tour coming don't you
have a
message
yeah